do if you broke your arm do you still
have an arm
[Music]
hi I'm brick hey I am Julian I am blind
and visually impaired so sometimes I'm
completely in the dark sometimes I can
see a little bit then I'm here to answer
some commonly googled questions about
blindness I've certainly heard the gamut
of questions all throughout my life so
yes I would say the dreams I went blind
two years ago so I still dream in full
color and audio since I lost my vision I
dream as oh I can see but I'm getting
around with a cane and they've
definitely become more audio yes we
absolutely do the stuff that's in my
dreams is based on what I have
experienced or sensed in life most
people who are blind have some level of
at the very least even light perception
in my case because I have some vision
there is some visual component to my
dreams I don't feel like I see extra in
my dreams versus what I see in the in
the in when I'm awake but it just
doesn't matter the lack of vision in my
dream doesn't get in the way of doing
anything in my dreams that people have
become more shadows and the people that
I think about or dream about are more
about what they make me feel like what
they smell like
what they sound like my favorite dreams
are the dreams where I'm flying do if
you broke your arm do you still have an
arm the answer is yes we still blinked
that doesn't do it the autonomic system
as far as I know for people that have
fake eyes they still blink so yes I
think blind people blink yes thank you I
do have friends also that are totally
blind and I believe they blink as well
I've even if you don't perceive any
light or anything through your eyes as
long as it is there and your eyelashes
and things are there you're going to
blink
I would say blindness is like seeing the
back of your head it's nothing it is
darkness but it's more of a lack of
vision I don't see black I see nothing
some people that are blind do see actual
black or dots or sometimes with me my
vision looks like a broken static
television but my blindness changes by
the day which is why I'm also visually
impaired I know I do because again my
yeah I do have some vision so for me
black is like night there's no light
there's nothing that it can be seen so
it's just it's just total darkness yes
yes we cry we're normal people we just
can't see like everybody else we are
humans like everybody else we do have
emotions and yes we experience sadness
loss pain we cry no it doesn't help your
hearing no the answer is we do not have
better hearing again we are not
daredevil we don't have this ability to
turn our ear and here's something from a
mile away
what it is is that we rely on our
hearing more than if you are lacking in
one sense the brain is gonna tap the
other senses a little bit more to try to
get that information since I've lost my
vision I have gained the abilities to
know which one of my family members is
approaching you based on footstep I can
hear things on the other side of the
house because I put an effort into it so
it's not that we'd get better hearing is
that we have to focus and work on our
other senses you do not have extra
Bionic supersonic hearing that's a myth
blindness is not the characteristic that
defines us it's not our badge
identification badge you know I mean if
all you see is blindness then you're
missing out on a whole lot you're
missing out I'm possibly meeting some
great friends you're missing out and
possibly hiring some of your best and
most loyal dedicated employees the
unemployment rate is so high in our
unity it's somewhere in the neighborhood
of seventy percent of working-age blind
people are either under or unemployed
it's just a matter of giving us a shot
and understanding that you need to look
beyond that white cane or beyond that
guide dog know that blindness is not the
thing that's gonna stand in our way and
you shouldn't let it stand in yours
there's also a feeling that we have in
our youth that we live forever
and that nothing bad will ever happen to
us but it's really not true I went blind
overnight and I could say it could
happen to anyone at anytime and I feel
very fortunate to have that perspectives
I appreciate every day as if it's my
last and I seize every moment I can and
that's one of the reasons why going
blind made me happier this is a vessel
that you live in and it can get hurt and
you're not invincible
I understand what life's actually about
and it's not about the little things
that stress throughout it's not about
focusing on those it's about the things
that really matter to you for me it's my
family I love to create I love my career
I love writing and that's what keeps me
going and I hope that maybe even if
you're sighted or have no disabilities
you can take that perspective and use it
on yourself and I hope that you could
enjoy your life with all the senses that
you have
[Music]
[Music]